استهداف متبادل على ارض سوريا هجوم اول
نفذته مسيره تعتقد واشنطن انها ايرانيه
استهدفت منشاه صيانه في قاعده لقوات
التحالف قرب الحسكه شمال شرق سوريا اسفر
الهجوم وفق البنتاجون عن مقتل متعاقد
امريكي واصابه اخرين
لترد واشنطن بضربات جويه دقيقه استهدفت
مستودعا للاسلحه في مدينه دير الزور ادت
الى مقتل سته مقاتلين موالين لطهران بينما
قتل اثنان اخران جراء ضربات طالت مواقعه
في باديه الميادين وريف الدو كمال بيان
البنتاغون الضربات الجويه جاءت ردا على
هجوم اليوم وسلسله من الهجمات الاخيره ضد
قوات التحالف في سوريا من جانب مجموعات
تابعه للحرس الثوري
هجوم يضاف الى سلسله من الهجمات التي شنت
في الاشهر الاخيره وتعرضت لها قواعد
ومواقع تابعه للتحالف الدولي وواشنطن في
شمال وشرق سوريا حيث ينتشر مئات من الجنود
الامريكيين في المنطقه ضمن تحالف يقاتل
عناصر داعش الى جانب تقديم الدعم لقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه ملوك الشيخ العربي